tras días de extensas protestas china
relaja las políticas de Cero covid en
varias ciudades residentes de la capital
Beijing así como el importante centro
financiero al sureste del país Shanghai
ya no tendrán que mostrar una prueba de
covid negativa para tomar el transporte
público ni para visitar parques
a su vez las cuarentenas podrían ser en
los domicilios y no en centros de
repulsión adecuados por el gobierno en
esta concurrida Estación de metro en
Shanghai hay posiciones ambivalentes
sobre la relajación de medidas algunos
celebran tener la libertad de decidir
Cómo sobrellevan un eventual contagio
si realmente contraigo este virus Espero
que el gobierno pueda permitirnos elegir
la cuarentena domiciliaria Espero que
después de cinco o seis días de
recuperación pueda salir a trabajar
nuevamente
pero a otros les preocupa que la gente
se relaje bastante
me sentí un poco preocupada porque
todavía tienes que protegerte no importa
dónde vayas las mascarillas no se pueden
quitar se ha abierto para todos Así que
debo prestar atención
pese a relajamiento por parte del
gobierno chino de algunas de las medidas
más drásticas desde Beijing aún
defienden la política de cero covid
la tasa de mortalidad y de síntomas
graves de covid-19 en China se mantiene
en un nivel relativamente bajo a nivel
mundial los hechos demuestran que en los
últimos años las políticas de prevención
y control de epidemias de China son
científicas y efectivas
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
aplaude al gobierno chino
estamos felices de ver el ajuste que es
muy importante para equilibrar la
necesidad de controlar la transmisión
del virus con las necesidades
socioeconómicas
la relajación de las medidas se da luego
de días de protestas contra la política
de Cero covid y tras la disminución de
la tasa de casos asintomáticos en
ciudades como Shanghai